in Großbritannien verschwinden jedes
Jahr 76.000 Kinder
bis zum Ende dieser Sendung werden es 10
weitere sein
[Musik]
die meisten von ihnen werden innerhalb
weniger Tage gefunden aber nicht alle
im März 2002 erschüttert das
Verschwinden eines jungen Mädchens die
britische Nation
eine 13-Jährige aus sorry wird vermisst
Amanda Dowler kam am
Donnerstagnachmittag nicht von der
Schule nach Hause
[Musik]
die Suche bleibt erfolglos
und weitere Experten haben den ganzen
Tag lang sterbliche Überreste untersucht
vom Vermisstenfall zum Mordfall es ist
die bis dato größte Ermittlung der
zuständigen Polizeibehörde wenn wir
diese Person nicht fassen wird es
weitere Opfer geben
doch der Fall hat noch einen anderen
Aspekt eine Geschichte vertraulicher
Besprechungen verdeckter Observationen
und lange geheimgehaltener Akten
wenn man so etwas entdeckt muss man
reagieren
mehr sage ich dazu nicht
damals wirklich geschehen
im totales Chaos die Ermittlungen liefen
kreuz und quer
und warum vergehen fast zehn Jahre bis
zur Verurteilung von Melis Mörder
was haben sie gesagt dass ich glaube zu
wissen wer sie getötet hat es geht um
Mord ein potenzieller Serientäter wir
hatten keine Ahnung wer es war
Machtmissbrauch wir dachten wir stünden
über dem Gesetz und so war es auch und
um verpasste Chancen hätten sie die
richtigen Schlüsse gezogen wäre es wie
früher zur Festnahme gekommen und das
hätte viele seiner Taten verhindert
[Musik]
ist eine hübsche gutbürgerliche Stadt in
Surrey viele Pendeln zur Arbeit nach
London es ist ein sicherer Ort
der Inbegriff der Vorstadt ruhige
begrünte Straßen Adresse ordentliche
Häuser absolute Mittelklasse
Jungen und Mädchen die sorglos von der
Schule nach Hause schlendern
[Musik]
ein gewöhnlicher Donnerstagnachmittag im
Frühling die 13-Jährige Amanda Doula
genannt Milli macht sich von ihrer
Schule in wabbridge auf den wenige
kilometerweiten Heimweg
normalerweise ist sie mit ihrer besten
Freundin Hanna unterwegs
wir haben uns keine großen Gedanken um
alle anderen gemacht weil wir auf unsere
Freundschaft vertraut haben sie war
solide alles andere war nicht so wichtig
[Musik]
schwer zu beschreiben denn sie war
manchmal sehr sensibel aber gleichzeitig
auch völlig durchgeknallt
einfach voller Energie immer am
rumalbern zeichnen tanzen wir haben gut
zusammengepasst ich war genauso verrückt
[Musik]
es schien ein ganz normaler Tag zu sein
Melli und ich wollten abends zusammen
die kunsthausaufgaben machen aber dann
ging ich nach der Schule zu einer
Sportveranstaltung also nahm Milli den
üblichen Zug nach Hause
es war alles wie immer
keinerlei Vorahnung dass etwas passieren
würde
Vorsicht an der Bahnsteigkante
[Musik]
nach der Schule stieg Milli in way
Bridge mit Freunden in den Zug
aus
eine Station früher als sonst und ging
mit Freunden etwas essen
von dort aus rief sie ihren Vater an um
Bescheid zu sagen dass sie jetzt von
Walton nach Hause gehen würde
[Musik]
sie von einer Schulfreundin gesehen
in der kurzen Zeit die millis Freundin
braucht um in den Bus zu steigen und aus
dem Fenster zu sehen verschwindet Melli
von der belebten Hauptstraße und ist wie
vom Erdboden verschluckt
[Musik]
Ausschau sah sie aber nicht mehr sie war
weg
[Musik]
Melli wird inzwischen seit mehr als drei
Stunden vermisst ihre Familie macht sich
große Sorgen
als es gegen 19 Uhr dunkel wird ruft
millis Vater Bob dauler die Polizei
[Musik]
im vermissten Fällen sind die ersten
Stunden entscheidend kriminalreporter
Jeff Edwards hat Kontakte zur servey
Police und erfährt von den Ermittlungen
Presse und Fernsehteams fallen in
Scharen in Worten und Tams ein während
die Polizei Suchtrupps mobilisiert
es wurde sofort ein umfassender
Polizeieinsatz veranlasst um dem Fall
auf den Grund zu gehen sie befragten die
Freundinnen mit denen sie zum Bahnhof
gefahren war Polizisten gingen von Tür
zu Tür und fragten ob jemand die junge
Frau gesehen hatte
die Polizei sucht vor allem rund um den
Bahnhof von Walton und tems wo Milly und
zwei Schulfreunde kurz vor ihrem
Verschwinden ausgestiegen sind
obwohl auf dieser beliebten Straße
reichlich Leute unterwegs waren konnte
die Polizei niemanden ermitteln der
Milli gesehen hatte es gab keine Spur in
dem Fall
[Musik]
Mellis Familie und Freunde sind
überzeugt dass etwas nicht stimmt
instantley es kam mir gleich komisch vor
weil es so untypisch für sie war sich
nicht bei ihren Eltern zu melden
da war was passiert
die Polizei verstärkt ihre Ermittlungen
sie laufen unter der Bezeichnung
Operation Ruby very quickman erkannte
schnell dass das ein großer Fall war
und es wurde Verstärkung herangezogen
es waren Ermittler der Abteilung für
Schwerverbrechen im Einsatz aber auch
lokale Polizeikräfte die in der Gegend
wohnten
ich erinnere mich an eine
Pressekonferenz der sorry poldies zu
diesem Fall bei der man uns sagte was
bisher unternommen worden war und dass
man ihre Freunde befragt hatte
sie suchten nach einer Spur nach
irgendetwas das Aufschluss darüber geben
konnte was mit Meli passiert
warten Sie einen heimlichen Freund mit
dem sie durchgebrannt war war sie die
prämiert hatte sie sich vielleicht das
Leben genommen
das Milli verschwunden war und wie sie
aussah
plötzlich steht die sorry Police im
Licht der Öffentlichkeit die Kleine
vorstadtbehörde wird von Einheimischen
und freiwilligen unterstützt
[Musik]
auf der Suche nach einer Spur von Milli
erfasst die Polizei alle
Überwachungskameras rund um den Ort an
dem sie zuletzt gesehen wurde
dieses Gebäude mit den Baugerüsten war
damals eine tiefkühlkostfabrik und auf
dem Dach war eine Überwachungskamera
installiert die Ermittler sahen sich die
Aufnahmen an aber die Kamera war so
eingestellt dass sie sich drehte und in
alle Richtungen filmte dadurch war der
entscheidende Straßenabschnitt etwa 50
Sekunden lang nicht zu sehen
das war sehr frustrierend für die
Polizisten als die Stelle ins Bild kam
an der sie Milli zu sehen hofften war da
nichts Show daraus schließen Sie das was
auch immer Milli widerfahren ist in
diesen 50 Sekunden passiert sein muss
die 13-Jährige scheint wie vom Erdboden
verschluckt
die Ermittler haben nicht die geringste
Spur
[Musik]
wir haben nothing nichts deutet darauf
hin dass sie aus freien Stücken
verschwunden ist
ebenso wenig haben wir Hinweise darauf
dass sie entführt wurde
wir ermitteln derzeit in alle Richtungen
während die Story Police noch immer
keine Spur hat befürchten die Menschen
vor Ort das schlimmste
wenn man sich das mal ansieht sie hatte
nichts bei sich außer der Kleidung die
sie trug sie hatte offenbar kein Geld
mitgenommen und keinerlei Dinge die ihr
wichtig waren außer ihrem Handy
dem Handy auf dem ihre Eltern sie
unablässig zu erreichen versuchen
milit
arring mom that Jamal Granny and all the
family
really miss you
doch während die Welt den Atem anhält
führen Journalisten und Privatermittler
eigene Recherchen durch und glauben das
Rätsel gelöst zu haben
[Musik]
sie dachten wir haben diesen riesenfall
geknackt
in den Tagen nach Milli Dallas
verschwinden macht die Polizei kaum
Fortschritte und die britische
Boulevardpresse stürzt sich auf die
Story
allen voran eine Zeitung mit fast 10
Millionen lasern
die News of the World War ausgesprochen
beliebt jeden Sonntag setzten sie mit
einer Story einen Schwerpunkt den andere
Zeitungen sehr oft an den
darauffolgenden Tagen aufgriffen
ein sehr mächtiges Blatt
die treibende Kraft hinter der
einflussreichen Publikation ist
Chefredakteurin Rebecca Brooks zwei
Jahre vor millis verschwinden hat sie
eine Kampagne zur Gesetzesänderung ins
Leben gerufen um den Schutz der
Identität verurteilter Pädophiler
aufzuheben Anstoß für die Kampagne ist
der Mord an der achtjährigen Sarah Payne
entsprechend wird die Kampagne als
Sarahs law benannt der erfahrene
boulevardjournalist Paul mcmullen
arbeitet damals bei der Zeitung
nach dem schrecklichen Tod von Sarah
Payne war Rebecca Brooks fest
entschlossen jeden verdammten Pädophilen
im ganzen Land zu entlarven
ein Sturm der Entrüstung geht durch die
britische Bevölkerung
wutentbrannte Bürger wären nehmen
Verdächtige ins Visier
[Applaus]
sofort dran an dem Fall das ist genau
meine Story geben wir die Marschrichtung
vor finden wir das Mädchen und lassen
wir uns als Helden feiern
die mächtige News of the World will
nicht nur über den Fall berichten sie
will ihn lösen
ihr schwesterblatt die Sun übertrumpft
die survey Police mit Millionen
veröffentlichten Fahndungsplakaten und
der Auslobung einer enormen Belohnung
Paul Samurai wurde vom verurteilten
Straftäter zum Journalisten er weiß wie
weit Zeitungen wie die News of the World
für einen Scoop einen Knüller gehen
[Musik]
für die News of the World zu arbeiten
hat viele Leute in den Wahnsinn
getrieben Bernsteine Norma
Leistungsdruck die Bezahlung war gut
aber Gott musste man dafür liefern
Besuchers müsste man sein ganzes Leben
opfern wie in einer Sekte das trifft es
wohl am besten die News of the World War
wie eine Sekte
der Oberguru war Mr Rupert Mörder und
seine Gefolgsleute waren die
Chefredakteure und wenn die unter Druck
gerieten setzte sich das fort bis runter
zu den Reportern vor Ort
ständig diese Anrufe wo bist du gerade
hast du was was machst du und dann warum
hast du nichts warum hast du es nicht
anders versucht
Wochen vergehen und der Druck steigt
Journalisten und Ermittler nehmen millis
Freunde ins Visier
sie tauchten schnell am Schulgelände auf
niemals auf dem Schulgelände aber direkt
davor man konnte ihnen also nicht aus
dem Weg gehen
sie fragten jeden ob er milikante unsere
Clique war ziemlich sauer dass
irgendwelche Leute die nicht mal auf
unsere Schule gingen in Artikeln über
Milli vorkamen und sie angeblich kannten
alle fragten sich wer ist denn das
[Musik]
das sind alles Zeitungsausschnitte aber
die Medien können bei der Suche nach
Milli auch hilfreich sein
meine Mama meinte wir müssen alles tun
um die daulers zu unterstützen darum
hatte ich viele Fernsehauftritte und
Zeitungsinterviews
man liest was oder sieht es in den
Nachrichten denkt wie furchtbar und
vergiss es dann wieder
aber es geht um meine beste Freundin und
es ist schwer damit umzugehen es ist wie
ein Albtraum den ich nicht von der
Realität unterscheiden kann
wir gehen lauter Dinge durch den Kopf
von denen ich nur hoffen kann dass sie
nicht passieren
Gesicht bekannt zu machen so dass ich
niemand an ihr vergreifen würde es gab
die Hoffnung dass sie noch lebte und
dass man sie erkennen würde
wenn jemand Milli entführt hätte Gott
bewahre was würdest du dieser Person
sagen
das bitte lassen Sie sie gehen
wenn zurück zu ihrer Familie das Leid
und die Ängste die ihre Familie ihre
Freunde
alle hier ausstehen das sind wirklich
unerträglich
[Musik]
es ist immer schwer zu sehen wie
Familien appella aussprechen das ist die
schlimmste Zeit ihres Lebens und sie
hoffen verzweifelt auf eine Nachricht
darum sind sie zu allem bereit und
begeben sich in diese belastende
Situation um ihre Tochter
zurückzubekommen wer würde das nicht tun
rufen Tag für Tag auf millis Handy an
[Musik]
die angerufene Mailbox ist voll dann
plötzlich gibt es einen
Hoffnungsschimmer
am 24 März rufen sie wieder an um eine
Nachricht auf Ihrer Mailbox zu
hinterlassen und plötzlich war die nicht
mehr voll sie nahmen an sie hätte wohl
ihre Nachrichten abgehört sei also noch
am Leben
doch jemand anderes könnte millis
Nachrichten abgehört haben
am 14 April bringt eine Zeitung eine
sensationelle Story
die News of the World War auf eine
Nachricht gestoßen die sehr bedeutsam
schien von einem Unternehmen in terfood
in tropischer das Milli offenbar einen
Job anbot
in der Story der News of the World vom
14 April wird eine Nachricht zitiert in
der jemand von der Jobagentur sagt hallo
Mandy wir rufen an weil jetzt die
Vorstellungsgespräche losgehen ruf mich
bitte zurück danke
bei der News of the World War man
deswegen ganz aufgeregt sie dachten das
wird eine exklusiv-story wir schicken
ein halbes Dutzend Leute dorthin und
finden Sie wir haben diesen riesenfall
geknackt
es schien als sein Willi noch am Leben
eine riesen Story
derartige Geschichten werden von einem
zwielichtigen Netzwerk aufgetan
wer Informationen braucht scheint mit
genügend Geld alles bekommen zu können
das hier sind die wohl bekanntesten
Privatermittler
diese privat Ermittler werden von
Zeitungen damit beauftragt geheime oder
vertrauliche Informationen zu erlangen
diese Leute haben Verbindungen zu
Telekommunikationsunternehmen oder zur
Zulassungsbehörde
und dann gibt es da Leute die Telefone
anzapfen können oder die an
Verbindungsnachweise kommen
diese Dienste in Anspruch zu nehmen war
für bestimmte Zeitungen ganz normal
ein Privatermittler glenmar care wird
von der News of the World für Recherche
und Information mit einer sechsstelligen
Summe entlohnt
ohne echte Untersuchung war nur möglich
wenn man zuverlässig Zugriff auf solche
Dienstleistungen hatte
und dabei geht es nicht nur um
prominenteuler dass ein großer Fall er
bekam viel Aufmerksamkeit die Story der
News of the World über millis Mailbox
schlägt ein wie eine Bombe und sie hat
Folgen für die Ermittlungen drei Monate
nach millis verschwinden hat die sorry
Police endlich eine Theorie zu dem Fall
wir sind verschiedene Hypothesen dazu
durchgegangen was mit Amanda passiert
sein könnte und gehen jetzt davon aus
dass sie von einem Gelegenheitstäter
entführt wurde
und wenn sie entführt worden ist hat die
sorry Police bereits ein wichtiges
Detail übersehen das womöglich alles
verändert hätte
in den Tagen nach Milli dowlers
verschwinden gelingt es der News of the
World Ihre Mailbox abzuhören dank eines
Vorgehens mit dem nur einige wenige
Privatermittler vertraut sind
[Musik]
bei neuen Handys bekam man über eine
voreingestellte PIN Zugriff auf die
Mailbox den meisten Leuten war nicht
klar dass sie die PIN ändern konnten sie
nutzten einfach weiter die
voreingestellte wenn man also diese
Nummer anrief und die PIN eingab konnte
man die Sprachnachrichten darauf Abhören
selbst man rief die Nummern von Promis
an landete auf der Mailbox und konnte
vielleicht eine überraschende Nachricht
hören daraus konnte man dann sicher was
machen
den News of the World hat millis
Handynummer von jemandem an ihrer Schule
bekommen aus der Nachricht auf Ihrer
Mailbox leitet das Blatt ab sie sei
womöglich am Leben und wohlauf doch die
Story ist haltlos
sie hofften auf eine sensationsstory und
das wäre sie auch gewesen wenn sie nicht
aus den falschen Gründen der falschen
Fährte gefolgt werden
es stellte sich heraus dass die
Nachricht für eine Frau namens Nana
bestimmt war die wohl fast die gleiche
Handynummer hatte wie Milli Dowler
jemand hatte anscheinend die Zahlen
verdreht also einfach ein Versehen
doch durch dieses Story wird die Story
Police auf die illegalen Praktiken der
News of the World aufmerksam
in diesem Schreiben legt die sorry
Police ihre Interaktion mit der News of
the World da
der Inhalt wird 10 Jahre lang geheim
gehalten bis die Öffentlichkeit
schließlich 2012 im Zuge einer
Untersuchung des abhör-skandals davon
erfährt
[Musik]
dem Schreiben zufolge kontaktiert die
News of the World die Polizei am 13
April 2002 und berichtet von einer
Sprachnachricht doch die Polizei bekommt
diese Nachricht erst eine Woche später
zu hören
sie konnten nur daran gekommen sein
indem sie sich in Milli dowlers Mailbox
gehackt hatten aber anstatt dem
nachzugehen drückten die Ermittler beide
Augen zu
den Medien gut zu stellen
[Musik]
eine weitere Untersuchung ein Jahrzehnt
nach den Ereignissen bestätigt dass die
Story Police damals keine Untersuchung
wegen der abhörpraxis der News of the
World einleitet laut Bericht fürchtet
man sich dort beinahe vor der Presse
im April 2002 scheint es als leite nicht
die Polizei die Ermittlungen sondern die
allmächtige britische Boulevardpresse
der erfahrene news of the
world-schreiber Paul MCM sieht darin
kein Problem
wir dachten wir stünden über dem Gesetz
und so war es auch
[Musik]
ein Presseausweis der News of the World
War wie eine Blanco Vollmacht
fast 30 Jahre lang haben die News of the
World die Sun und morox gesamtes
Unternehmen jedem Premierminister von
Großbritannien ins Amt geholfen darum
hat sich die Polizei unter dem Einfluss
der Regierung auch gesagt lassen wir sie
in Ruhe die haben praktisch
Narrenfreiheit
ich bin bei so vielen Verfolgungsjagden
über rote Ampeln gefahren es war einfach
egal
wir konnten auch problemlos bei Behörden
Autokennzeichen Abfragen
leitender Ermittler und Beamte gingen
mit Rebecca Brooks und Andy coulson
einen trinken und besuchten sich
gegenseitig mit den Redakteuren der News
of the World zu Hause zum Abendessen
und wenn es oben so läuft setzt sich das
bis nach unten fort
reportete
mit größtem Respekt behandelt
Monate verstreichen und die unermüdliche
Suche nach Milli geht weiter
das Team hatte niemals dienstfrei und
die Arbeitstage waren lang mein aß
irgendwas wenn man dazu kam ging ins
Bett stand am nächsten Morgen wieder auf
und ging direkt wieder zur Arbeit bis um
22 Uhr so sah der Tag aus
doch eine wichtige Spur ist bereits
übersehen worden
rund 5 km von dort entfernt wo Mili
verschwunden war hatte es einen Vorfall
gegeben
ein elfjähriges Schulmädchen namens
Rachel Carls lief diese Straße entlang
als eine kleine rote Limousine neben ihr
hielt ein Mann fuhr das Fenster herunter
und sagte Hallo ich bin dein neuer
Nachbar soll ich dich zu Hause absetzen
und sie sagte nein danke ich bin ja
gleich schon da ich gehe zu Fuß
sie erzählte ihrer Mutter was passiert
war und die informierte die Polizei
Rachels Mutter erzählt den Beamten von
dem Fremden im roten Fahrzeug die
versuchte Entführung von Rachel geschah
genau 24 Stunden vor Milis in Führung in
Walton der Anruf bei der Polizei wird
zwar vermerkt aber nicht an das Team
weitergegeben dass in millis Fall
ermittelt
die tragischerweise ging man dem nicht
nach hätte die Polizei die Mittel gehabt
hätte das womöglich alles verändert
das Team das Milli dowlers verschwinden
wenige Kilometer weiter untersucht wird
nicht über die versuchte Entführung
eines anderen Mädchens informiert damit
könnte ein Tatverdächtiger davongekommen
sein
es ist nicht das erste Mal dass der
sorry Police vorgeworfen wird Straftaten
gegen Minderjährige nur halbherzig zu
verfolgen
im Jahr 1958 wird das walkenhop eröffnet
es gilt als erste Disco Großbritanniens
und auf der Tanzfläche drängen sich
Jugendliche aus der Umgebung
[Musik]
doch in den 70er und 80er Jahren gibt es
Gerüchte Männer aus der show-branche
würden sich dort an Minderjährige heran
machen
damals können sich Prominente darauf
verlassen dass ihr Ruhm sie schützt und
das niemand unbequeme Fragen stellt nach
der Schließung des worten-hop brechen
Betroffene die dort als Minderjähriger
missbraucht wurden ihr Schweigen
2001 kurz vor Milli Dallas verschwinden
ruft die sorry Police Operation aaronder
ins Leben Pädophile die im
walton-hop-aktiv waren sollen zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden der
ehemalige Radiomoderator Chris Denning
wird verurteilt vier seiner Übergriffe
ereigneten sich im walton-hop
musikmogul Jonathan King wird 2001 zu
sieben Jahren Haft verurteilt
ein weiteres Ermittlungsverfahren gegen
Jonathan King im Jahr 2018 scheitert der
zuständige Richter macht die sorry
Police dafür verantwortlich dort soll
man früheren Anschuldigungen gegen den
Moderator Jimmy sevill nicht
nachgegangen sein und Kings Verteidigung
den Zugang zu einem entsprechenden
Bericht erschwert haben der vernichtende
Bericht legt da dass die Art der
Befragung von Missbrauchsopfern in
Surrey und zuverlässige Ergebnisse
hervorbringt als Melli Dowler 2002
verschwindet werden die Methoden der
Saray Police also mancherorts bereits
kritisch beäugt
viel besser ich habe hier ein paar
Erinnerungsstücke
das ist meine Dienstmütze
hier ist mein alter Dienstausweis
eine andere Polizeibehörde führt eine
Routine Überprüfung der Ermittlungen im
militarlerfall durch Kevin Moore von der
Sussex Police leitet die Überprüfung
[Musik]
es war ein Chaos um ehrlich zu sein
ich hätte erwartet dass eine Ermittlung
dieses Ausmaßes anders geführt wird
es gab keine klaren Ermittlungsansätze
da läuten die Alarmglocken man fragt
sich worauf läuft das hier hinaus wie
bringen wir es wieder auf die Spur so
wie es sein sollte
[Musik]
doch bevor nur seinen Bericht darlegt
gibt es eine dramatische Entwicklung im
Fall milliaula
[Musik]
gut 30 Kilometer entfernt macht ein
Pärchen beim Pilze sammeln die
Entdeckung die alle befürchtet haben
zwischen dem drei und der A30 nachlädt
den helmscher haben Tatort Ermittler und
weitere Experten den ganzen Tag lang
sterbliche Überreste untersucht heute
abend brachten vorläufige
Untersuchungsergebnisse dann die
traurige Gewissheit
unsere schlimmsten Befürchtungen haben
sich bewahrheitet ich muss Ihnen
mitteilen dass die Suche nach Miley vom
Vermisstenfall zu einer morduntersuchung
geworden ist
[Musik]
Kevin Neid und suday von der sorry
Police erinnern sich an diesen schwarzen
Tag
wurde erst nach sechs Monaten gefunden
es hat auch erst Jahre später oder
niemals passieren können denn in diesem
Waldstück ist kaum jemand unterwegs
wegen des Wasserlaufs hier
[Musik]
ja es ist irgendwo in diesem Bereich
es ist immer seltsam an den Fundort der
Leiche eines Mordopfers zu kommen
egal wie viele Leute vor Ort sind es
wird immer ganz still
[Musik]
selbst jetzt würde ich nicht dorthin
gehen wollen ich auch nicht ich halte
lieber Abstand ich möchte da nicht
drüber laufen
genau
das war ein gewisser Weise ihre letzte
Ruhestätte darum halten wir lieber etwas
Abstand
für millis Familie brachte das die
schreckliche Erkenntnis dass sie die
Hoffnung aufgeben musste hier endete die
Suche damit war die Hoffnung am Ende
[Musik]
das war der schlimmste Tag meines Lebens
wo furchtbar das einfach ja William
wirklich schlimm Willi abseits
irgendwie war man erleichtert dass sie
zumindest gefunden worden war das hätte
ja auch anders sein können
aber dann setzte der Schmerz ein dass
sie nun nie mehr wiederkommen würde
Milli war nicht mehr am Leben was
sollten wir jetzt tun
[Musik]
von meinem Zimmerfenster aus konnte ich
immer den Polarstern sehen und ich
redete mit ihm als wäre es Miri daran
hielt ich mich fest
meine Eltern dachten wohl ich würde mich
in den Schlaf weinen aber ich weinte mit
Melli also das sprach mit ihr das hat
mir geholfen mich irgendwie mit ihr
verbunden zu fühlen
aber man findet keinen Umgang damit
warum dort warum an dem Tag man sagt
sich immer wieder sie war zur falschen
Zeit am falschen Ort
aber sonst hätte es jemand anderen
getroffen denn nun ist klar Milli Dallas
Mörder ist noch auf freiem Fuß er ist
einer umfangreichen Suche der Polizei
entkommen und könnte erneut zuschlagen
eine furchtbare Vorstellung dass diese
Person noch irgendwo da draußen war
[Musik]
fast ein Jahr ist seit der Entführung
und Ermordung von militarler vergangen
doch die sorry Police ist dem Täter noch
keinen Schritt näher gekommen
[Musik]
hi hallo doch ein paar Kilometer weiter
im Zuständigkeitsbereich der
Metropolitan Police führt eine Reihe
brutaler Übergriffe auf junge Frauen
schon bald zu einem völlig neuen
Ermittlungsansatz im Fall milliaula
das waren furchtbare Übergriffe quasi
direkt vor unserer Tür
[Musik]
8 km von Walton und Tams entfernt wird
eine Studentin brutal angegriffen
eine junge Frau
McDonald fiel einem Angriff mit einem
stumpfen Gegenstand zum Opfer sie starb
an den Folgen sie war abends unterwegs
und zwischen 21 und 23 Uhr fand der
tödliche Angriff statt wenige Meter von
ihrer Wohnung entfernt
es gab keinerlei Spuren am Tatort keine
Fasern oder sonstige Anhaltspunkte
hatte hatte es entweder schon einmal
getan oder sich sehr gut vorbereitet um
nicht gefasst zu werden
[Musik]
im Mordfall Marsha McDonald kann kein
Täter ermittelt werden
18 Monate später kommt es zu einer sehr
ähnlichen tat
[Musik]
keine drei Kilometer vom letzten Tatort
entfernt wird eine junge Französin
überfallen
den ganzen Tag über haben Spezialisten
nach Spuren gesucht die zu Ergreifung
des Mörders von Amelie de Lagrange
führen könnten die 22-Jährige fiel einem
brutalen Angriff zum Opfer als sie nach
einem Abend mit Freunden nach Hause ging
schwere Kopfverletzungen als jemand am
trickin am green auf sie losging wenige
Meter von hier entfernt
im Zentrum von Twickenham mit Freunden
etwas trinken sie stieg dort in einen
Bus und hätte auf dem Weg zu ihrer
Wohnung hier drüben an der Haltestelle
aussteigen müssen aber aus irgendeinem
Grund verpasste sie den Ausstieg
wir wissen inzwischen dass sie die
Hemden Road zurücklief das zeigen die
überwachungsaufnahme sie kürzte hier
über die Grünfläche ab um zu ihrer
Wohnung zu kommen und wurde dabei
überfallen wir hatten eine ermordete
junge Frau und keinerlei Hinweise auf
den Täter
dasselbe Team das den Mord an Marsha
untersucht hatte ermittelte auch im Fall
Amelie de Lagrange
schon allein die Eckdaten zwei junge
blonde Frauen rund um Twickenham beide
mit einem stumpfen Gegenstand erschlagen
da wird man ja schon hellhörig
die beiden Fälle wurden sofort
miteinander in Verbindung gebracht
womöglich war es ein Serientäter
das scheint sie Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
mehr als eine Person in derselben Gegend
auf dieselbe Art agiert ist ehrlich
gesagt verschwindend gering
wenn man es mit einem Serientäter zu tun
hat ist absolute Eile geboten wenn man
diese Person nicht fasst sterben
Menschen
meines Wissens hat noch kein Serientäter
gesagt mir reicht es jetzt ich höre
damit auf ihn zu fassen ist der einzige
Weg ihm das Handwerk zu legen
die Jagd nach dem potenziellen
Serientäter beginnt die Polizei weiß
dass die beiden Opfer Amelie de Lagrange
und Marsha McDonald kurz vor den
Angriffen im Großraum London aus einem
Bus gestiegen sind
ein anderer Fahrgast kam nicht als Täter
in Frage das wäre aufgefallen jemand
musste den Frauen in einem Fahrzeug
gefolgt sein
das Ermittlungsteam musste tausende
stundenmaterial von Überwachungskameras
sichten man darf nichts übersehen keine
Sekunde
fest installierte Kameras Kameras in
Streifenwagen und vor allem in Bussen im
Bus Kameras erfassen auch was ich
außerhalb des Buss und so stießen wir
auf den weißen van
wir konnten ermitteln dass es ein weißer
fort Carrier van war und das war
praktisch alles was wir hatten wie viele
weiße Vans sind in London unterwegs
tausende fast 25.000 weiße Vans müssen
überprüft werden
die Polizei sucht einen kleinen weißen
van der am Abend von Amelies Ermordung
in der Nähe von Twickenham green gesehen
wurde dort wurde sie abends auf dem
Heimweg erschlagen
meine Aufgabe war es jedes Fahrzeug in
der Polizei Datenbank zu überprüfen ich
habe 1800 Fahrzeuge überprüft
Angeln war klar was das für eine Arbeit
war
während die Metropolitan Police nach dem
Mörder sucht geraten die Ermittlungen im
family Gauler in Surrey ins Stocken
zwei Jahre sind eine lange Zeit in einer
mortermittlung ohne jeden Anhaltspunkt
selbst am Fundort von Melis Leiche gab
es keine DNA-Spuren keine Fingerabdrücke
keine Mordwaffe ihre Kleidung wurde
nicht gefunden auch nicht ihre
Schultasche nichts es gab keine
Ermittlungsansätze
wir hatten nicht den Eindruck dass
irgendeiner unserer Ansätze
erfolgversprechend war
nichts brachte uns wirklich weiter
aber man bleibt weiter dran man sucht
nach dem einen Puzzleteil dass eine ganz
neue ermittlungsrichtung eröffnet nach
der einen großen Erkenntnis der beste es
war eine sehr schwierige Ermittlung wir
fragten uns ob wir den Fall je lösen
würden
in der britischen Zeitungslandschaft
kommen derweil immer mehr Fragen zu
dubiosen Vorgehensweisen auf vor allem
jenen der News of the World seit
Jahrzehnten ist die Zeitung ein
Verkaufsschlager am Sonntag Anfang der
2000er Jahre hat sie noch immer die
höchste Auflage und bringt einen Knüller
nach dem anderen doch die Beteiligten
Journalisten ahnen nicht das schon bald
deren Ende bevorsteht
alles beginnt mit der Durchsuchung einer
Privatdetektei im Süden Londons
[Musik]
die Behörden haben ein Unternehmen im
Visier das des Datenklaus im großen Stil
verdächtigt wird Chef Ermittler Alec
Owens ist beim Einsatz vor Ort
bei der Durchsuchung lief ich durch die
Büroräume und sei beiläufig was dort so
auf dem Schreibtischen lag
dabei fiel mir Bündel von Unterlagen auf
darunter eine lange Liste von
Nummernschildern mit dem Buchstaben E
für S6
Kennzeichen bei deutlicher als
geschützte Nummer markiert es gehörte
also wohl zum Privatfahrzeug eines
Mitglieds der königlichen Familie oder
wurde bei verdeckten Ermittlungen
eingesetzt
und das liest bei mir die Alarmglocken
läuten
die Zulassungsbehörde darf auf
Informationen zu diesen Kennzeichen
zugreifen
da schließen wir auf Steve
der das Kennzeichen abgefragt hatte
ein Privatdetektiv der mehrere britische
Zeitungen mit Informationen versorgt
darunter auch die News of the World
Owens Ermittlung nimmt ein Fahrt auf sie
läuft unter dem Namen Operation motorman
watermore's House wird als nächstes
durchsucht dort finden die Ermittler
tausende Unterlagen und vier dicke
Bücher voller belastender Informationen
darüber wie die Zeitungen an ihre
Knüller gekommen sind
darin war jeweils der Name des Verlags
aufgeführt
der Name der Zeitung
der Name eines Journalisten
daneben die Anfrage für eine
Dienstleistung zwar sind einige der
Anfragen legal viele sind es jedoch
nicht die Geheimunterlagen zeigen das
korrupte Beamte witamore mit
sozialversicherungsunterlagen versorgen
mit Geheimnummern und sogar mit Akten
aus der nationalen Polizeidatenbank und
rittermore gibt diese Informationen an
zahlende Journalisten weiter
17.500 Anfragen von 310 identifizierten
Journalisten
Owens Ermittlungen legen offen wie
Journalisten an viele ihrer Stories
gekommen sind nicht nur in Bezug auf
prominente sondern auch in Fällen wie
dem von milliarler
schließen auf mehrere Namen die mit
Opfern von Verbrechen oder mit
Mordopfern Zusammenhängen wie Sarah pain
und militarler es fanden sich Adressen
und Telefonnummern ihre Familien in den
Unterlagen an die kann man nicht auf
legalem Wege
Alec Owens und die Operation motorman
haben klare Beweise gesichert rittermore
und andere werden verurteilt doch die
Journalisten die für Informationen
gezahlt haben kommen davon wieder einmal
zeigt sich wie mächtig die Presse ist
Owens sagt sogar er sei davor gewarnt
worden die Ermittlungsergebnisse
öffentlich zu machen je nach
Entschuldigung von der Presse hieß es
einfach ich dachte so dass ein Scherz
sein wie könnte ich nicht gegen die
Presse Vorgehen sie verstoßen gegen das
Gesetz
würde jemand auf der Straße erschossen
werden und man geht nicht hin um dem
Täter die Schusswaffe abzunehmen uns
Chef sagt er könne sich nicht erinnern
etwas derartiges gesagt zu haben und
streitet es ab
wenn man so etwas entdeckt muss man
reagieren
[Musik]
september 2004 das Ermittlungsteam das
den brutalen Mord an Amelie de La Grange
am Twickenham green im Südwesten von
London untersucht hofft verzweifelt auf
Hinweise aus der Bevölkerung eine Woche
nach dem Vorfall betritt eine Frau die
Polizeiwache
nach dem Mord an Amelie Diller grunge
ging ich zur twerken im Green
Einsatzzentrale und machte eine Aussage
was haben sie gesagt dass ich glaube zu
wissen wer sie getötet hat
als Johanna Collings von dem Mord an
Amelie de La Grange erfährt hat sie nur
einen Gedanken sie kennt einen Mann dem
sie die Tat zutraut
[Musik]
als sie fragten warum glauben Sie den
Täter zu kennen sagte ich weil der Vater
meiner Kinder mein Ex-Partner
gewalttätig ist Blondinen hast sich gut
in der Gegend auskennt und einen weißen
van fährt weil er parkkrallen anlegt
und wie hieß er
mein Ex-Partner war Levi befield
callings hat nicht nur einen Verdacht
sie ist sich sicher
es war richtig zur Polizei zu gehen es
ging nicht um Rache sondern darum dem
ein Ende zu setzen
wie viele Menschen sollten noch sterben
bis er aufgehört hätte und das hätte er
nicht getan er hätte weiter gemacht
[Musik]
er war aus der Gegend und kannte sich
dort aus und laut seiner Freundin hatte
einen weißen fORD COURIER van und war zu
so einer Tat in der Lage
jeder nur ja
vom ersten Tag an weil sie ihn
durchschaute und ihn nicht leiden konnte
ich glaube sie hat gesehen dass er böse
und manipulativ war
sagte manchmal er sei gemein und sie
wisse was los sei auch wenn ich es nicht
zugeben wollte ich habe es immer abgetan
weil ich meiner Mutter gegenüber nicht
zugeben wollte dass ich misshandelt
wurde
niemandem gegenüber
etwas zeigte uns wie bellefield im
Zusammenleben war was für ein Mensch er
war und das eindeutig Gefahr von ihm
ausging bei dem aus meiner Sicht war er
ganz klar zu den Taten in der Lage um
die es hier ging
jetzt da das Ermittlungsteam bergfield
im Visier hat geht es darum ihn zu
überführen doch das will sorgfältig
geplant sein
er hatte viele Möglichkeiten irgendwo
unterzukommen er war viel unterwegs
viele Frauen viele Freunde und Bekannte
bei denen er Unterschlupf kriegen konnte
es wurde ein überwachungsteam auf ihn
eingesetzt um ihn im Auge zu behalten
das folgte ihm bis noch little Panty in
West righton hier wollte man am Morgen
des 22 November zuschlagen
doch mitten in der abschließenden
Planung taucht ein Störfaktor auf in
Gestalt der News of the World
das Problem war dass die News of the
World am Freitagnachmittag sagte wir
wissen dass ihr lieber bellfield
verdächtigt und ihn Montag früh
festnehmen wollt darüber berichten wir
am Sonntag
habe ich gesehen welcher Taktiken sich
die Presse manchmal bedient um an
Informationen zu gelangen aber ich hatte
noch in keiner Ermittlung erlebt dass
wir unsere Pläne ihretwegen ändern
mussten
jemand hat sie informiert ja
es gab schon immer undichte Stellen bei
der Polizei
manche Behörden in denen nicht
gearbeitet habe hatten mehr undichte
Stellen als ein Sieb
mancherort kann man sich sicher sein
dass die Medien sofort über
ermittlungsdurchbrüche Bescheid wissen
sie müssen also eine Quelle bei der
Polizei haben
die Polizei verhandelt mit der News of
the World die Zeitung druckt die
Geschichte nicht ab so dass berfield
nicht gewarnt wird im Gegenzug dürfen
ihre Journalisten beim Zugriff vor Ort
sein
die Polizei war um halb sechs Uhr
morgens hier mit einem Team von rund 30
Leuten durch die Überwachung war klar
dass balefield im Haus sein musste das
war der entscheidende Moment
sie brachen die Haustür und die
Hintertür auf aber bellefield wandertens
zu sehen also machten sie sich daran das
Haus zu durchsuchen
sie überprüften alle potenziellen
Verstecke Ecken Schränke jedes Zimmer
unter den Betten alles noch immer keine
Spur von ihm damit blieb nur noch der
Dachboden das Team holte eine Leiter und
stieg hoch zur dachbodenluke und fand
ihn schließlich unter der
dachbodendämmung splitternackt
die Polizei hat ihren Verdächtigen und
die Presse ihres Story
es gibt Fotos wie ich mit ihm auf der
Rückbank Sitze eher in Handschellen
etwa zur gleichen Zeit als berfield
festgenommen wird kommt eine Information
ans Licht die zu einem schockierenden
Verdacht führt
als wir Battlefield unter die Lupe nahm
überprüften wir alle Fahrzeuge und
Adressen mit denen in Verbindung stand
eine dieser Adressen war calling wood
place
[Musik]
mir stellten sich die Nackenhaare auf es
lagen nur Mieter zwischen der Stelle an
der Militär Roller zuletzt gesehen
worden war und belfields damaliger
Adresse
wer fehlt ist der Verdächtige der
Metropolitan Police jetzt informiert die
Ermittlungsbehörde die sorry Police
deren Ermittlung im Mordfall milliaula
mehr oder weniger zum Stillstand
gekommen ist
bearfields damalige Adresse könnte der
Durchbruch sein den man in sorry
verzweifelt benötigt
ich schrieb meiner Kollegin zu day dass
wir einen neuen Ermittlungsansatz hatten
wir fuhren gleich am Vormittag zum
callingwood Place um uns die Gegend
anzusehen und ein Gefühl dafür zu
bekommen wo er gewohnt hatte
wenn man auf die Wohnung zugeht ist da
eine Lücke in der Hecke von der
Erdgeschosswohnung aus in der er gewohnt
hat konnte man durch diesen Durchgang
die Station Avenue sehen
nicht mal so baff waren wir von der
Erkenntnis wie nah balefield im Ort
gewesen war an dem Milli zuletzt gesehen
wurde
es war gruselig mir lief es kalt den
Rücken runter
sehr standen beide da und dachten das
ist der der Durchbruch in dieser
Ermittlung
doch eine Zeitung schreibt der Polizei
hätten zum Zeitpunkt von Milli Dallas
verschwinden 2002 bereits 93 Beschwerden
über barfield vorgelegen wegen Vergehen
wie sexueller Belästigung und
körperlicher Übergriffe
angeblich sei die Polizei dem nie
nachgegangen
und trotzdem hätte berfield schon in den
Anfangstagen der Untersuchung gefasst
werden können
[Musik]
die sorry Police führte nach ihrem
Verschwinden eingehender Erkundungen in
der Gegend durch 11 Mal kamen Beamte für
eine haustürbefragung zur Wohnung am
Collingwood place aber es machte nie
jemand auf und so wurden sie nicht auf
ihn aufmerksam
sie waren mindestens 11 mal an der
Wohnung und es machte nie jemand auf
hätten Sie damals die Zusammenhänge
erkannt während sie balfield
wahrscheinlich auf die Spur gekommen und
er wäre viel früher festgenommen worden
das hätte viele Menschen vor Angriffen
durch ihn bewahrt
Davos
[Musik]
die Sussex Police führte zwei
Überprüfungen der Ermittlungen durch die
sorry Police durch ohne dabei
schwerwiegende Versäumnisse
festzustellen
wir müssen akzeptieren dass Fehler
gemacht wurden dennoch wäre der Verdacht
auch bei einer mustergültigen
anfangsuntersuchung womöglich nicht auf
Battlefield gefallen es war langwierig
komplex und schwierig und hat viele
Jahre akribischer Ermittlungsarbeit
erfordert
die Polis hat endlich einen
Hauptverdächtigen im Mordfall miliaula
doch es gibt lediglich Indizien Beweise
barefield sitzt wegen des Mordes an
Amelie de Lagrange und anderer
Verbrechen in Untersuchungshaft äußert
sich aber nicht zum Fall milliaula
[Musik]
das Ermittlungsteam ist überzeugt den
Täter zu haben braucht allerdings
Beweise die finden sich langsam aber
sicher
wie bei einem Puzzle kamen immer mehr
Hinweise zusammen das ist der Kopenhagen
way der am Collingwood place verläuft
und diese Kurve hier sollte eine
wichtige Rolle in den Ermittlungen
spielen es stellte sich heraus dass Levi
bellfield unter anderem mit
Autoverkäufen sein Geld verdiente er
wechselte häufig den Wagen und das Team
nahm alle Autos unter die Lupe die er im
Laufe der Jahre gefahren hatte und eines
der Autos auf die er Zugriff hatte war
eine rote d-ju Nexia Limousine
der Mann der am Tag vor Mili Dallas
verschwinden versucht hat das
Schulmädchen Rachel Karls zu entführen
vor ebenfalls eine rote Limousine
noch einmal durchgehen mit einem ganz
neuen Schwerpunkt
die Polizei sichtet die alten Aufnahmen
unter einem neuen Gesichtspunkt
genau jetzt hielten wir nicht nur nach
einer vermissten 13-jährigen Ausschau
sondern nach Levi belfield
als das Ermittlungsteam die Aufnahmen
vom Dach der tiefkühlkostfabrik erneut
sichtete fiel auf dass ein Auto hier um
die Kurve kam rund 20 Minuten nach
millis verschwinden
der rote derbou liefert der Polizei eine
Verbindung zwischen barefield und
miliedowlers Entführung gibt es nun auch
noch eine Verbindung zum Fundort ihrer
Leiche könnte der Fall gelöst sein
Gruß Jungs hopp
das ist das wackelige alte Tor
so sicher wie eh und je
während Joe Collins mit leerwei belfield
zusammenwohnt kommt sie an den
Wochenenden zum Springreiten hierher
kamen alle dieses Feld war der Parcours
hier wurde geübt er war immer ganz stolz
wenn sich die Pferde gut machten das
fand er toll und hat es jedem erzählt
er war immer dabei und wollte mit zu den
Veranstaltungen
und wir fragten joe ist Ihnen diese
Gegend bekannt und sie ja ich bin da
jedes Wochenende zum Springreiten er
kennt sich da gut aus
wir fuhren mit ihr hin und ließen uns
zeigen wo das Springreiten stattfand
vor Ort sagte sie dann er war nicht die
ganze Zeit hier er ging auch mal mit den
Hunden über die Straße also ließen wir
uns auch diese Gegend zeigen
[Musik]
gut als wir in den Wald gingen kamen
wieder Stelle näher und näher
irgendwann sagte sie dann hier haben wir
normalerweise kehrt gemacht und zu Day
und ich sahen uns an was Joe wohl
bemerkte sie fragte wurde Melli hier
gefunden
es war wirklich nicht weit weg nur ein
paar hundert Meter
es ist ein grauenhaftes Gefühl zu wissen
dass ich so nah an diesem Ort war das
bricht mir das Herz
[Musik]
woher sonst sollte er die Gegend kennen
denn man muss sich auskennen um zu
wissen wo man eine Leiche verstecken
kann
das war ein Durchbruch die Polizei
sammelt immer mehr Indizien gegen
berfield doch die entscheidende
Information kommt von Emma Mills seiner
Partnerin zum Zeitpunkt von milliaulas
Entführung
als die Beamten ihre Aussage zum Tattag
durchgehen stoßen sie plötzlich auf das
fehlende
puzzleteils konnte der Polizei sagen wo
sich belfit am Tag der Tat und am Abend
aufgehalten hatte und das war
entscheidend für die Ermittlungen
der rote debo auf den
überwachungsaufnahmen ist ihrer Mails
zufolge ist befehlt am Tag lange
unterwegs die Schlüssel zum roten devo
und zur Wohnung am callingwood Place hat
er am selben Bund um 23 Uhr kommt er
nach Hause steht aber um halb vier Uhr
morgens wieder auf um wie er sagt allein
zum calling wood place zurückzufahren
als Ermittler denkt man sofort was will
er dort die Wohnung putzen eine Leiche
wegschaffen
und als sie reinkam fiel ihr sofort auf
dass das Bett abgezogen war
[Musik]
er sagte der Hund hätte es schmutzig
gemacht sie fragte wo denn die Laken
hingekommen sein und er sagte er hätte
sie in den Müll geworfen
sie glaubt ihm nicht sie dachte es sei
eine andere Frau in der Wohnung gewesen
darum sah sie in den Mülltonnen nach und
dort waren keine Laken zu finden
der rote der wo die Putzaktion am
Collingwood place Ortskenntnis im
Waldgebiet bei jetli die Indizien
reichen aus neun Jahre nach dem Mord an
Mili Dowler wird Leroy bellfield
angeklagt
[Musik]
ich fuhr hierher kurz bevor das
Verfahren anfing hinten ist die Wohnung
in der die Tat geschah es war ein
furchtbares Gefühl ins Schlafzimmer zu
blicken und zu wissen was dort passiert
war das ging mir sehr nahe und hat mich
nicht mehr losgelassen
[Musik]
wer fehlt ist für die Morde an Amelie de
La Grange und Marsha McDonald bereits zu
lebenslanger Haft verurteilt worden
2011 steht er schließlich wegen des
Mordes an Milli Dowler erneut vor
Gericht
es war mir sehr wichtig dabei zu sein
Kevin und ich hatten so eine enge
Verbindung zu den Zeugen dass es sehr
persönlich war
der Justizbeamte fragte sind sie zu
einem einstimmigen Urteil gelangt und
sie sagten ja
das Urteil ist gefallen
schuldig
wenn das Urteil verkündet wurde haben
wir beide ziemlich heftig reagiert
es war eine Explosion der Gefühle anders
kann ich es nicht beschreiben von der
Familie von Freunden der Polizei und der
Presse sowas habe ich noch nie erlebt
[Musik]
das ist einfach grauenhaft dass jemand
einem einen Menschen wegnimmt und so
viel Leid verursacht ich bin wütend dass
er es getan hat und solange davon
gekommen ist dass er noch mehr Menschen
verletzt hat das ist erschütternd das
ist danach noch mehr Opfer gab
im selben Jahr findet ein weiteres
Gerichtsverfahren statt in dem Milli
Dallas Geschichte eine entscheidende
Rolle spielt
[Musik]
keine zwei Wochen nach barefields
Verhandlung berichtet der Guardian die
News of the World habe sich in Miley
Dallas Mailbox gehackt drei Tage später
verkündet Inhaber Rupert Mörder das
endgültige Aus der Zeitung
[Musik]
das war das Gelände von News
International wo auch die News of the
World ansässig war
das war der Tempel der Sekte
was man jetzt hier sieht ist das Ende
der News of the World
was ein Stier war gibt es jetzt nicht
mehr
es ist wirklich
independent publicing place als Sinus
Praxis
dieser neue Bericht wurde von der
Regierung in Auftrag gegeben und befasst
sich mit Bedenken bezüglich der Presse
Auslöser war öffentliches Entsetzen
angesichts des Abhörens der Mailbox
einer ermordeten Jugendlichen
die Eltern von milliaula sind wichtige
Zeugen
in einer Demokratie überwacht eine freie
Presse die mächtigen aber bis auf wenige
ehrenvolle Ausnahmen ist die Presse im
Vereinigten Königreich dieser Rolle
bezüglich ihrer eigenen Macht nicht
nachgekommen
[Musik]
erst wie die Fakten zweifelsfrei und in
zu vielen Fällen zeigen ist diese
Verantwortung einfach
ignoriert worden
das muss sich ändern
[Musik]
so ich bin eine Patchwork das hing immer
ein Bild von Millie in der
Einsatzzentrale das Bild eines
13-jährigen schulmädchens
als das Gerichtsverfahren schließlich
lief waren alle ihre Schulfreundinnen
Erwachsene 21-Jährige mit Jobs
das führte uns noch mal vor Augen was
Milly alles verwehrt geblieben war
heiraten
ein Haus kaufen Kinder haben
man muss bei allem daran denken das ist
sicher sehr schwer für die dowlers
sie sind die stärksten Menschen die ich
kenne
wundervolle Menschen
Hunde
vergisst man nicht einfach aus den
wenigen Jahren mit ihr habe ich
wunderschöne Erinnerungen mitgenommen
die ich für immer im Herzen tragen werde
[Musik]